l'un des grands enjeux du déconfinement
à venir sera de tester un maximum
d'individus plus on testera plus on
pourra contenir le risque de covin 19
avant que celui ci ne nous échappe
comme l'expliquent le directeur général
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
we can't stop hispaniques et we don't
know who is in fact oui a simplement
c'est drôle car il reste cependant comme
vous avez sans doute déjà entendu parler
le problème est qu'il ya une pénurie de
test on manque de capacité à tester en
tout cas à tester par pcr qui semble
être à l'heure actuelle la seule manière
de déterminer avec grande prudence si un
individu est contagieux et s'il doit
être isolé alors je veux beaucoup de mal
à trouver des chiffres fiables sur la
capacité de test mais à en croire cette
publication de l'institut des politiques
publiques où ces données de world in
terra il semble y avoir autour de cent
mille tests de covit 19 en france par
semaine et 30000 en suisse avec cent
mille tests par semaine en france
on ne peut pas tester tout le monde il
semble même difficile de tester tous
ceux qui ont des symptômes
cependant de nombreux efforts sont mises
en oeuvre pour augmenter la capacité des
tests et certains espèrent atteindre une
capacité de 500 mille tests par semaine
pour le déconfinement taste test test
voilà qui serait sans doute
indispensable pour avoir une chance de
conserver rt en dessous de 1
y compris en déconfinement même s'il me
semble qu'il faut être méfiant vis-à-vis
de ce chiffre et au moins envisager le
cas où une sort est possible d'effectuer
que par exemple 300 mille tests par
semaine le 11 mai et pendant les longues
semaines voire les mois qui suivront
cependant même cinq cent mille tests par
semaine risque d'être insuffisant voire
même très insuffisant en tout cas si on
ne s'appuie pas sur d'autres solutions
comme on l'a vu dans l'épisode précédent
isoler les individus symptomatique ne
suffira pas le grand défi posé par la
coved dix neuf c'est que en temps normal
près de la moitié des contaminations
semble être prêt symptomatique pire
encore plus les interventions sur les
symptomatiques sont efficaces plus la
part de contamination très symptomatique
augmentera et donc plus il sera
important de tester les individus prêts
symptomatique pour leur demander de se
mettre en quarantaine s'ils sont
positifs à la coved 19 test test test ce
moment il ya autour de 10 ont vingt
mille nouveaux cas confirmés par semaine
cependant vu la pénurie de tester le
problème des prêts symptomatique ce
chiffre est certainement une grâce aux
estimations il ya sans doute plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de nouveaux cas
contagieux par semaine y compris des cas
très symptomatique
malheureusement chaque semaine
identifier une fraction non négligeable
des dizaines de milliers d'individus
prêts symptomatique en particulier est
un défi monumental
ces individus sont similaires à une
tumeur qui se propage avant que
quiconque ne sache que le patient a une
tumeur
ils peuvent alors causé des dégâts
terribles et l'on pourrait s'en rendre
compte seulement des semaines plus tard
en particulier ces individus prêts
symptomatique permettront probablement
au virus de se propager à un rythme
exponentiel si aucune intervention
efficace sur ces individus n'est préparé
on risquerait alors un second
confinement avec tous les risques
sociaux économiques et sanitaires
horrible qui l'accompagnent dans ce
contexte il est urgent d'identifier les
cas suspect d'individus potentiellement
près symptomatique
pour y arriver toutefois il semble qu'un
minimum de surveillance sera
indispensable tout comme surveiller un
minimum les risques de tumeurs chez des
patients à risques est indispensable par
chance il n'est toutefois peut-être pas
nécessaire de viol est trop gravement
les données personnelles des citoyens
par exemple via des applications comme
dp 3 t et pour plus de détails sur dp 3
t je vous renvoie vers cette vidéo bien
qu'imparfaite cette solution dp3 t
pourra permettre d'identifier les
risques de contamination en traçant les
contacts des personnes positives à la
coved 19
voilà qui aiderait à notifier les
personnes qui pourraient être prêts
symptomatique est contagieuse et ensuite
prioriser ces personnes dans les tests
de kobe de 10,9 et ainsi maximiser
l'efficacité des tests en nombre limité
cependant le risque de kovy de 10,9
mesurée par le contact racing sera
lui-même sans doute insuffisant pour
distinguer suffisamment correctement les
vrais cas de co vite 19 des fausses
alertes
après tout même parmi les individus
symptomatique en france sur dix
individus testés qu'après ces données
seulement deux ou trois sont positifs
le taux d'individus positifs parmi les
individus à risque identifié par le
contact racing sera probablement bien
plus faible surtout si on veut tester
tout individu dès qu'il est un peu à
risque pour manquer aussi peu que
possible des cas probables de contagion
très symptomatique
supposons que le taux de co vide et 19
parmi les individus identifiés comme
étant à risque soit de 10 ont une
personne sur 20 chaque semaine pour
détecter cinquante mille nouveaux
individus infectés parmi les individus
identifiés à risque cette semaine là il
faudra alors effectué 20 x 50 minutes
qui est égal à 1 million de tests
touched test test
ainsi même avec le contact tracing 500
mille tests seraient très insuffisant et
encore là j'ai supposé qu'on disposait
d'un contact pressing efficace et très
adoptée par la population française sans
contact racing il semble que détecter
une fraction non négligeable des cas de
kovy de 10,9 près symptomatique soit
désespérée à moins peut-être de réussir
à dépister beaucoup plus de cas sans
tester plus
le problème de la rareté des tests est
en fait un problème étudié depuis
plusieurs décennies par les
mathématiciens qui ont proposé des
solutions pour augmenter le dépistage
sans augmenter le nombre de tests en
exploitant des tests dits groupe et tout
a commencé avec une note de robert
dorfman pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale pour dépister davantage de cas
de syphilis avec un nombre limité de
test le problème a ensuite été
généralisée notamment par chaud sion
glee en 1962 qui lui a donné une saveur
beaucoup plus mathématique et peut-être
également un peu moins pratique
plus récemment en l'an 2000 doux et wang
ont publié un livre qui compile des
décennies de travaux sur le sujet et qui
présente de nombreuses applications au
delà du domaine médical
et puis au cours des dernières semaines
plusieurs travaux ont appelé à
l'application des idées de dorfman lee
doo et wang au test de kobe 19 après en
avoir vérifié la faisabilité clinique t
elle des airs en appliquant des méthodes
tout à fait raisonnable il est possible
de dépister deux à trois fois plus
d'individus dans le cas d'une population
à 5 % de risques les outils de test
groupe et deviendront encore plus
efficace s'il s'agit de tester une
population ayant seulement un pour cent
de risques avec un x 7 du nombre
d'individus tester on pourrait même
atteindre du x 30 ou du foie 40
si jamais on voulait tester chaque
semaine toute la population française en
s'appuyant sur des tests groupe et deux
millions de tests par semaine pourrait
alors être suffisant pour pouvoir tester
chaque semaine tous les citoyens
français même si bien sûr ça poserait
d'autres problèmes notamment des
problèmes d'ordre logistique taste test
test avant d'aller plus loin je vais
même vous présenter la solution que je
préconiserais en tout cas en l'état
actuel de mes connaissances notamment
car cette solution est à la fois très
efficace mais aussi et surtout
remarquablement simple a plombé la
probabilité de covin 19 dans une
population donnée pour tester les
individus de cette population
on forme d'abord des groupes de taille
environ un sur racine carrée de paix
donc si paix est égale à une personne
infectée sur 20 dans la population des
individus identifiés par exemple par le
contact racing alors il s'agirait de
former des groupes de taille environ
racine carrée devant les groupes doivent
être un nombre entier donc par exemple
ici on peut prendre des groupes de
taille
on collecte alors un échantillon de
chaque individu du groupe qu'on me dise
on dans un tube à essai on collecte 1/2
échantillon de chaque tube à essai et on
mélange ce qu'on a obtenu août est alors
le mélange par exemple avec un test pcr
si le résultat du test est négatif alors
tous les individus du groupe sont
négatifs
on peut donc garantir à tous ces
individus qui sont négatifs en ayant
utilisé qu'un seul test pour 5 personnes
sinon si le résultat est positif alors
on teste chaque individu du groupe
séparément on aura alors effectué six
tests pcr au lieu de cinq
cependant la probabilité qu'on ait
besoin d'effectuer ces tests individuels
est alors de 1 mois 1 - pétition 5 qui
est égal à 23 % donc 77 % du temps on
effectue un seul test alors que 23 % du
temps n'ont effectué 6 en moyenne
on aura effectué 2,1 tests pour dépister
cinq individus
c'est 2,3 fois moins que si on avait
fait directement des tests individuels
voilà qui nous permet donc j'ai testé
deux ou trois fois plus de personnes
avec le même nombre de tests et donc de
tester plus d'un million d'individus par
semaine avec seulement cinq cent mille
tests par semaine ça fait une énorme
différence
taste test test la stratégie qu'on vient
de présenter et l'algorithme que dorfman
a introduit dans son article 2 1943
c'est un algorithme qui al'avantage
d'être très simple à comprendre a
expliqué et sans doute aussi à effectuer
en pratique
bon alors bien sûr il ya quelques
précautions à prendre pour l'application
pratique et j'avoue que les sciences
expérimentales c'est très loin d'être ma
zone de confort et j'ai du mal à oser
donner moi même des recommandations
cependant cet article semble discuter
très judicieusement des risques et
suggèrent fortement que cette procédure
est vraiment applicable en pratique dès
lors il me semble important de moins
envisagés l'application des tests groupe
et pour les cas peu probable de covin 19
à plier les tests groupe et pourrait
peut être grandement modifié notre
capacité à contenir la pandémie actuelle
et en particulier les contaminations
près symptomatique
l'algorithme de dorfman et techniquement
légèrement différent de celui que j'ai
présentées en effet plutôt que de
prendre des groupes de taille cas est
égal à 1 sur racine carrée de paix on
peut optimiser encore un peu plus la
valeur précise de cas pour cela en
appelant quarantaine le nombre total
d'individus à tester on peut remarquer
que le nombre de tests groupe et qu'il y
aura à faire est égal au nombre de
groupes qui est égal à haisnes / k ainsi
la première étape de l'algorithme
dorfman qui consiste en ces tests groupe
et comporte t1 est égal à haisnes / cac
teste la seconde étape consiste à
traiter individuellement les groupes
positif on a vu que la probabilité qu'un
groupe soit positif est la probabilité
comment un individu du groupe est
positif en supposant ces probabilités
indépendante
la probabilité d'un groupe positif est
alors un mois 1 - p puissance qu'a tient
groupe est positif alors il faut tester
tous les individus du groupe ce qui fait
qu'à test comme ce raisonnement est
valable pour chaque groupe pour obtenir
le nombre moyen de tests dans cette
seconde étape il faut multiplier tout
ceci par le nombre total de groupe
ainsi le nombre moyen de tests pour la
seconde étape sera t2 qui est égal à 1
mois 1 - p puissance qu'a fois qu'à fois
n / k qui est égal à 1 - 1 - pepsi en ce
cas fois n ainsi le nombre total de test
est égal à tempus t2 qui est égal à 1 /
k + 1 - 1 - p puissance qu'a fois haine
et en particulier le nombre moyen de
tests par individu testée est égal à t /
n qui est égal à 1 / k + 1 - 1 - p
puissance car il se trouve que cas est
égal à 1 / racine carrée de paie donne
un bon score pour le nombre moyen de
tests par individu mais on peut chercher
à mieux optimiser ce score
malheureusement il n'y a pas de jolies
formules pour y arriver mais un
programme informatique qui arrivera très
bien en pratique en fonction de la
valeur de paix même si a pas énormément
à gagner à optimiser vraiment la valeur
de 40 juste pour se rendre compte de
l'efficacité des tests groupe et aussi
quelques estimations de ce qui pourrait
être fait peut-être même dès à présent
pour l'instant seuls des individus
symptomatique ou à fort risque et sont
testés c'est pourquoi de nos jours
environ un test sur cinq est positive
appliquant un test groupe et de dorfman
avec k égale trois individus par groupe
on augmente de 22 % le nombre
d'individus dépistés par test c'est déjà
non négligeable avec cent mille tests
par semaine on pourrait dépister 122
mille personnes
mais maintenant si paix est égale à une
personne sur dix la taille optimale
serait qu'à égale 4 et on dépiste ray
alors 168 milles personnes avec cent
mille tests super est égale à une
personne sur vingt comme on l'a vu la
taille optimale et cas égale 5i et on
dépiste eura 235 mille individus
enfin un sip est égale à une personne
sur 100 la taille optimale et cas
égalent 11 et elle permettrait de
dépister
cinq cent dix mille individus avec son
hit est
il est toutefois possible de faire mieux
de dorfman pour y arriver lee willy
palais je suis pas en train de parler de
moi elle lit donc à proposer une
généralisation très naturel de
l'algorithme dorfman qui consiste en s
étapes au lieu de deux alors en pratique
il semble peu utile de considérer les
cas où s est vraiment très grand qui
pose toutes sortes de problèmes
pratiques additionnel et qui ne font pas
gagner tant que ça cependant le ks égal
3 demeure très intéressant notamment si
la probabilité p14 positif est très
faible ce qui arrivera si on veut tester
une grosse partie de la population dans
une première étape cette fois on va
considérer des groupes de taille k1 est
égal à 1 / p puissance deux tiers six
pay est égale à 1 %
on aura alors qu'un est égal à 21 comme
précédemment on teste l'écart individus
du groupe de manière groupée et donc
avec un seul test
si le test du groupe est négatif alors
l'écart à individus sont négatifs à
l'aco vide 19
dans une seconde étape on regroupe les
individus des groupes positif et on
forme cette fois des groupes de taille
k2 est égal à 1 / p puissance un tiers
type est égale à 1 %
ça nous fait cadeau est égal à 5 on
effectue alors un test groupe et pour
chaque groupe de cinq individus
si le test est négatif alors les cinq
individus du groupe sont négatifs à la
colite 19
enfin dans une troisième étape on teste
individuellement tous les échantillons
des individus restants noter que le
nombre moyen de tests par individu
correspond désormais à une formule un
peu plus complexe à savoir la formule à
l'écran
encore une fois les quantités qu'un est
égal à 1 / pub sens deux tiers et k2 est
égal à 1 / p puissance un tiers ne sont
pas optimales mais elles sont très bien
en pratique et peuvent d'ailleurs être
justifiée par l'analyse du pire qu'a
faite par lee quoi qu'il en soit dans le
café est égale à 1 % 40 égal à 21 et k2
est égal à 5
l'algorithme du test groupe et à trois
étapes de vie permet un nombre de tests
moyen par individu égal à 0,13
autrement dit ce test la 3 étape
permettra de tester cette fois plus
d'individus crainte est individualisé
c'est assez nettement mieux qu'un test
groupe et à deux étapes qui
nécessiterait 0,2 test par individu soit
cinq fois plus d'individus testé qu'un
test individualisé le test à trois
étapes
des pistes 1 6 50% individus en plus que
le test à deux étapes
mieux encore l'efficacité d'un test à
trois étapes est d'autant plus marqué
que la proportion d'individus positif
est faible typiquement pour tester
chaque semaine l'ensemble de la
population française soit 70 millions
d'individus en supposant disons 70 mille
nouveaux cas par semaine
on aurait alors p est égal à 0,1 pour
cent donc le test à trois étape
consisterait en car est égal à 100 et
cadeaux est égal à 10 ce qui permettrait
alors de dépister 34 individus par test
il suffira alors de seulement 2 millions
de tests par semaine pour tester toute
la population française chaque semaine
je dois bien dire que ce résultat
il m'a un peu mangold a contrario le
groupe à deux étapes nécessitera de
faire des groupes de cas est égale à 34
individus ce qui permettra de dépister
16 individus par test c'est beaucoup
mieux que des tests individualisé mais
ça reste deux fois moins que le test à
trois étapes
dans ce cas il faudrait 4 millions de
tests par semaine pour tester tout le
monde
chaque semaine l'algorithme de lits à
trois étapes seraient en fait efficace
même avec des tests moins invasif avec
cent mille tests cip est égale à une
personne infectée sur dix parmi les
personnes dépistées avec caïn est égal à
7 et k2 est égal à 3 on dépiste aurait
177 mille individus
c'est presque dix mille individus de
plus que si on applique l'algorithme de
dorfman 6 pi est égale à une personne
sur 20 avec caïn est égal à 9 et k2 est
égal à 3 on dépiste aurait 2 174 mille
individus
enfin comme on l'a vu ce type est égale
à une personne sur cent avec ucar ans
est égale 1 24 et k2 est égal à 5 ou des
pistes auraient 769 1000 individus soit
près de deux cent soixante mille
individus en plus qu avec l'algorithme
de dorfman nous encore si on fait
reculer lakovic 19
on pourrait avoir seulement peut-être
dix mille nouveaux cas par semaine
auquel cas la probabilité paix d'avoir
la cote est de 19 pour la population
globale serait de un sur sept mille
l'algorithme de dorfman étaient
optimales pour k est égal à 85 et des
pisterait environ 4 millions d'individus
avec cent mille tests
mais l'algorithme de lits à trois étapes
avec 15 est égal à 370 et k2 est égal à
20 ferait beaucoup beaucoup mieux
puisqu'il des pistera 12,4 millions
d'individus
cinq cent mille tests seraient
suffisants pour dépister quasiment
l'entièreté de la population française à
terme si le nombre de nouveaux cas
descend en dessous de dix mille et s'il
est possible de faire des tests groupé
avec plusieurs centaines d'échantillons
d'individus différents alors le
dépistage hebdomadaire total de la
population pourrait devenir une option
vraiment envisageable
notez que si on en arrive là alors le
contact racing ne sera probablement plus
nécessaire investir très massivement
dans le dépistage systématique à très
grande échelle pourrait suffire à
assurer un confinement sécurisé tel stld
test test
toutefois ces tests hebdomadaires
pourraient être considérés eux mêmes
très invasif surtout si on veut
certifier qu une majorité écrasante de
la population aura été testé toutes les
semaines ce qui semble être une
condition sinequanone à l'efficacité
d'une approche sans contact tracing mais
surtout produire des millions de tests
par semaine ne semble malheureusement
pas très réaliste dans les mois qui
viennent même si j'espère
personnellement que des moyens vraiment
importants seront dépensés dans
l'augmentation de la capacité à tester
modèle jusque là
toutefois sur certaines hypothèses qu'il
est possible d'affiner en premier lieu
il ya le problème de la précision des
tests malheureusement les tests pcr ne
sont pas parfaits il faut s'attendre à
des faux positifs qui n'est pas
nécessairement si dérangeant mais aussi
à des faux négatifs ce qui est peut-être
plus gênant d'après cette analyse de
find la sensibilité du test c'est à dire
la probabilité d'avoir un test positif
sachant qu'on a là qu'ovide 19 et proche
de 100%
cependant les intervalles de confiance
sont souvent de la forme 93% 100 % ce
qui suggère que les tests pourraient
avoir un taux de faux négatif de 0 à 7 %
si ce taux est de 5 % alors un individu
sur 20 ayant lakovic 19 risque de
recevoir un résultat négatif et donc de
baisser sa garde
à tort et ça peut être très préoccupant
puisque certains suggèrent un taux de
faux négatifs allant jusqu'à 30% pour
des tests pourtant individualisé en fait
suite à des discussions privées avec des
gens plus ou moins du domaine
il semblerait que la principale cause
des faux négatifs soit des erreurs de
manipulation ou des collecte
d'échantillons grattés dans le cas des
fausses manipulations
alors il est peut-être possible que des
tests groupe et pourrait diminuer le
taux de faux négatifs puisque il diminue
aussi le nombre de tests à effectuer par
personne dans le cas des erreurs par
mauvaise collecte d'échantillons qui se
comprend vu à quel point c'est difficile
d'aller chercher les échantillons à
tester les tests groupe et n'augmente
pas le risque de faux négatifs
ainsi il semble que les tests groupe et
pourrait peut-être être prometteur y
compris vis-à-vis du risque de faux
négatifs
quoi qu'il en soit il semble important
de moins envisagés le risque que 5%
voire davantage au des tests sur des
individus positive à la comique 19 donne
malencontreusement des résultats
négatifs
alors est-ce grave bien il faut comparer
ce taux d'erreur du test au taux
d'erreur globale dans la détection des
individus contagieux si on loupe tous
les individus prêts symptomatique par
exemple car le contact racing n'est pas
ou peu adopté alors la moitié des
individus contagieux pourraient avoir
baissé leur garde aux aussi en un sens
le problème des prêts symptomatique
semble dix fois plus préoccupant que le
cas des test négatif alors ceci dit on
pourrait avoir un problème grave
si en faisant des tests groupe et le
taux de faux négatifs augmenter
radicalement
il s'agit en effet d'un problème auquel
il est crucial de prêter attention
surtout si on commence à faire des
groupes de 100 individus d'après cet
article de l'institut des politiques
publiques
les premières données suggèrent que le
risque des faux négatifs dans était ce
groupe et ne semble pas si important que
cela
même s'il faut rester très prudent
vis-à-vis de ce risque
bref avant deux groupes et les tests il
faut tester des tests copé et pour
accélérer sa tête il faut qu'il y ait
des tests groupe et pour tester les
tests coupé hashtag métal hmida
une autre hypothèse importante
notre modèle est que les individus ont
une même probabilité d'avoir lakovic 19
et qui est indépendante des probabilités
d autres individus
et bien bonne nouvelle en exploitant
davantage les particularités des
individus ainsi que la corrélation entre
la santé par exemple d'individus qui
vivent dans le même foyer
il est possible d'augmenter l'efficacité
des tests groupe et d'une certaine
manière on a déjà exploité les
différences a priori entre individus
ainsi un individu avec des symptômes
prononcé qui semble avoir une
probabilité supérieure à 25% d'avoir
lakovic 19 devrait en fait être tester
directement individuellement les
individus dont les symptômes sont moins
prononcés ils ont on estime la
probabilité d'avoir la copie de 19 à
quelque chose entre 10 et 25% pourrait
être testé par groupes de trois ceux qui
ont une probabilité entre 1 et 10 %
peut-être par exemple car ils ont été
identifiés par le contact racing
pourraient eux être testé par groupes de
six enfin le reste de la population
pourrait être testé avec l'algorithme de
lits à trois étapes
par ailleurs il plus judicieux de
regrouper dans le même test groupes et
des individus qui ont une probabilité
importante d'être tous positifs ou tous
négatifs
typiquement les individus d'un même
foyer ou les collègues d'un même bureau
devrait être testé en même temps car le
fait qu'un de ces individus à la cause
19 augmente la probabilité qu'un autre
individu du même groupe là lui aussi
en fait en fonction de la force de
corrélation entre les individus du
groupe
un test groupe et de plus grande taille
devrait alors être envisagée car il est
alors plus probable que tous les
individus du groupe soient tous négatifs
dans le cas extrême d'une population
avec des foyers de cas est égal à 20
individus ou pour chaque foyer soit
personnes infectées soit tout le monde
est infecté et en supposant que le
risque individuel est de 5% alors en
testant chaque foyer de manière groupée
le nombre moyen de tests par individu a
effectué sera de 1 sur cas plus paix qui
est égal à 0,1 l'efficacité de tels
tests groupe et serait alors deux fois
10 contre seulement x 2,3 dont le cas de
tests groupé pour des groupes aléatoire
de taille kkl 5
alors là c'était un cas extrême de
corrélation en pratique il s'agit de
trouver un juste milieu dans la taille
du groupe en fonction de la proximité
entre les individus du groupe
malheureusement mesure et ceci n'est pas
facile
il n'y a pas de jolies formules pour
choisir la taille optimale des groupes à
tester là encore le contact tracing
combinée à des algorithmes d'analysé de
données plus sophistiqués pourraient
être très utiles pour dépister plus en
testant moins
on a vu aujourd'hui que les tests groupe
et semble être une approche très
efficace pour augmenter le dépistage
sans augmenter le nombre de tests
surtout quand il s'agit de tester des
populations dans la probabilité d'avoir
lakovic 19 est faible voilà qui semble
critique
sachant qu'un déconfinement sécurisé et
nécessitera très probablement le
dépistage massif d'individus sans
symptômes en effet comme on l'a vu dans
un épisode précédent
les contaminations par des individus
prêts symptomatique représentent une
part importante des contaminations par
kobe de 19 et ce sera sans doute encore
plus le cas si les individus
symptomatiques sont mis rapidement en
quarantaine dans ce contexte tout
astuces capables d'augmenter
significativement le nombre de personnes
dépistées est bonne à prendre surtout si
l'astuce est simple à mettre en oeuvre
or on a vu que les tests groupe était
très simple et qu'il pouvait doubler
voire parfois décupler le nombre de
personnes dépistées avec le même nombre
de tests
we can't stop and we don't know who is
in fact for all countries test test
malheureusement je n'ai pas eu le temps
de rentrer un peu plus dans les
mathématiques des tests groupe et pour
mieux comprendre ce qui peut être fait
avec ces techniques et en particulier
jouera vraiment adoré vous parler
davantage de l'entropie de shannon bon
si j'ai le temps et si je me motive
je serai peut-être de faire un youtube
live quelque chose comme ça pour en
parler cependant à moins d'effectuer des
millions de tests par semaine les tests
groupe et ne suffiront probablement pas
à dépister chaque semaine une majorité
de la population pour espérer contenir
la pandémie sont recourir un confinement
d'autres mesures drastiques semble
nécessaire notamment pour identifier
plus efficacement les individus sans
symptôme à risque à l'instar de ce qui a
été fait en corée du sud
il semble qu'une voie de sortie
sécurisée du confinement nécessitera des
outils de test et de contacts racing
très optimisé il semble possible
peut-être même probable que ce ne sera
qu'à cette condition que la majorité de
la population pourra enfin retrouver
durablement ses libertés de circulation
et que l'économie pourra empêcher la
faillite de nombreuses entreprises et le
licenciement de millions
d'employés